il est hélas devenu évident que la
technologie à dépasser notre humanité
sont les mots qu'a prononcés le prix
nobel albert einstein en 1935
et aujourd'hui à l'aube d'une nouvelle
ère technologique et mot résonne
particulièrement fort
a fait 25 ans qui travaille dans la
technologie d'abord comme start up
heures dans l'intelligence artificielle
puis à la tête d'un fonds
d'investissement spécialisé dans la tech
qui opère dans toute l'europe dans la
silicon valley en asie et en afrique
cela me donne un point d'observation
privilégié sursis que ce qui se prépare
dans la tête pour les 5 à 10 prochaines
années
je suis venu ce soir vous partagez mon
optimisme sur la tech mais aussi
quelques craintes et vous proposer un
défi
que ça fait des décennies que la tech
connaît une croissance exponentielle
et d'ailleurs ce qu'avait prédit le
scientifique gordon moore avec ta loi
qui porte son nom dès 1965 la vitesse
des microprocesseurs allait doubler tous
les 18 mois
cette loi a fait 57 ans qu'elle est
vraie
en 1985 le top de la tech s'est elle est
super computer credo un joli bébé de 2
tonnes 5 2 milliards d'opérations par
seconde et la consommation énergétique
d'un village français
aujourd'hui l'iphone 13
et 200 grammes et 15 trilliard
d'opérations par seconde ça tient dans
la poche et dix mille fois petit et dix
mille fois plus puissant
oui la tech est dans une croissance
exponentielle mais le problème est que
notre cerveau humain n'est pas capable
de comprendre ce qu'est une
exponentielle
d'ailleurs est quoi une exponentielle
vais vous donner un exemple
vous êtes au stade de france vous êtes
tout en haut des gradins au dernier
étage 38 mètres de haut
et là il se met à pleuvoir sur la
pelouse
premières secondes une goutte
deuxième seconde de gut
3e seconde quatre gouttes et ainsi de
suite en doublant le nombre de gouttes à
chaque seconde c'est à dire une
progression exponentielle
ainsi au bout de 10 secondes il est
tombé l'équivalent d'un dé à coudre sur
la pelouse d'après vous combien de temps
faudrait-il avec cette plus
exponentielle pour que le stade de
france se remplissent d'eau tout entier
jusqu'en haut des gradins
alors d'habitude on me dit un an
un mois
certains
10 un jour
non
avec cette pluie exponentielle le stade
de france se remplit d'eau jusqu'en haut
des gradins en seulement 47 secondes
ces 2 x 2 x 2 x 2 x 2 47 fois
ci une seconde de pluie ces 18 mois
d'évolution des processeurs alors dans
notre ère technologique on en est à la
37e seconde
au bout de 37 secondes et à peine des
flaques d'eau sur la pelouse
et vous dire l'évolution qui nous a tant
en termes de technologie dans les 10 à
15 prochaines années
alors évidemment avec cette pluie
d'innovation exponentielle on doit
s'attendre à des projets des progrès
exponentiels
d'ici la fin de la décennie
l'intelligence artificielle va remplacer
l'homme dans tout un tas de tâches
répétitives manuel visuel
conversationnel la voiture autonome va
complètement changer notre mode de vie
et la manière dont on vit dans nos
villes
l'ordinateur quantique va résoudre des
problèmes que l'informatique ne sait pas
résoudre aujourd'hui
prouvé de nouvelles molécules trouver de
nouveaux traitements médicaux optimiser
notre consommation énergétique et
peut-être résoudre une partie de la
crise du climat la réalité virtuelle va
révolutionner l'éducation le
divertissement des réseaux sociaux
mais est-ce que innovation veut vraiment
dire progrès
en fait une innovation est un progrès
que si elle rend l'homme plus humain et
non pas un esclave
voilà notre risque est que notre
humanité se dilue dans ce tourbillon
exponentielle de la tech
depuis 4 minutes depuis que je vous
parle il ya eu 2 millions de nouvelles
story sont instagram il ya eu un million
de swype thirteen d'heure il ya eu 200
millions de messages whatsapp échangé il
ya eu 500 millions de vidéos vues sur
tik tok
voilà le temps de la tech avec la tech
on est dans l'instantané le tout tout de
suite la machine elle connaît comme ça
elle connaît le temps de calcul ce temps
infiniment cours
nous les humains nous avons besoin de
tant de temps longs il faut neuf mois
pour n'être il faut deux ans pour
apprendre à parler il faut 18 ans pour
être adulte bon un peu plus quand on est
un homme
les humains ont besoin de temps de
plusieurs temps un temps de vie
personnel à temps pour la famille un
temps de travail un temps de repos un
temps pour les amis un temps de
méditation de spiritualité c'est dans ce
temps long que s'épanouit notre liberté
intérieure dans laquelle il ya plus de
place pour soi même il ya plus de place
pour les autres il ya plus de place pour
dieu quand on est croyant
c'est tout le sens du shabbat chez les
juifs ce jour de repos ce jour où on se
déconnecte de tous pour mieux se
reconnecter à soi même aux autres et
vivre sa spiritualité
paradoxalement la tête nous fait gagner
du temps
avec le travail à distance on économise
en moyenne une heure de trajet par jour
une heure par jour et un mois de temps
libre par an
et pour autant est ce qu'on a vraiment
l'impression d'avoir plus de temps
qu'avant
non parce que là finn ray engloutit tout
le temps qu'elle nous fait gagner
il ya un milliard d'utilisateurs sur tik
tok et tous les jours passent 52 minutes
à regarder des vidéos ces 52 milliards
de minutes passées par l'humanité ou
plutôt perdu par l'humanité et quid
pourrait servir à quelque chose servir à
quelque chose qui compte vraiment
il faudrait rajouter le temps passé sur
facebook sur instagram sur snap sur
fortnight sur blocks et tous les autres
metaverse
cette addiction
on y succombent tous
et quand je perds mon temps devant un
écran
est ce que je deviens plus humain ou
esclaves
elle vous rappelle rien cette pomme à
moitié croquer au dos de nos smartphones
la pomme d'adam et eve
elle est là la tentation mais traverse
dans notre poche
grâce à cette pomme j'ai beaucoup plus
de mémoire
mais j'ai moins de connaissance et
beaucoup plus d'informations
mais
j'ai aussi beaucoup plus de followers
moins d'amis
grâce à cette pomme je me connecte à
l'autre bout du monde
mais je m'isole de ce qui m'entoure
parts à cette pomme je gagne un temps
fou et je gaspille des journées entières
et par un hasard si steve jobs le
fondateur d'apple a déclaré
j'échangerais toute ma technologie
contre un après midi avec socrate
oui cette technologie c'est un grand
pouvoir qui nous est donnée et avec tous
grands pouvoirs dont une grande
responsabilité
cette responsabilité elle nous incombe à
tous créateurs d'entreprise
investisseurs utilisateurs clients
parents grands parents il nous est posée
une question de civilisation à quoi
allons-nous décidé de passer notre temps
d'ici la fin de la décennie
l'intelligence artificielle va nous
rendre à peu près trois mois de temps
libre par an
nous exposer cette question si on me
donne aujourd'hui
trois mois de temps en plus par an à
quoi vais-je décidé de le passer
c'est 7 vision il façonnera le monde de
demain
et non pas la technologie elle-même
c'est cette décision qui définira notre
civilisation technologique et la manière
de vivre ensemble c'est cette décision
qui transformera l'innovation en progrès
pour tous et cette décision elle nous
appartient à tous dès ce soir
alors je vais vous demander de prendre
votre smartphone dans la main
allez-y
vous avez le mettre en mode avion
et quand c'est fait
vous aller allumer votre lampe par un
concert
où la tenue autour d'un au dessus de
votre tête voilà maintenant regardez
autour de vous toutes ces lumières qui
s'allument
chaque lumière c'est un être humain qui
se reconnecte au monde réel
pendant sept minutes ya zéro story sur
instagram
il ya zéro message whatsapp ya zéro
vidéos vues sur tik tok voilà le temps
de l'homme voilà ce temps l'on nous
avons besoin
alors je vous propose un défi dès demain
passons une heure par jour en mode avion
et alors nous pourrons commencer à
changer le monde